nuit blanche j- 2 depuis 2002 à Paris
chaque année l'opération permet
gratuitement durant la nuit bien sûr de
découvrir musées et institutions
culturelles des installations de
performance également artistiques sont
proposés 50 ans nieline n'est pas en
reste s dit des coins vous nous disiez
tout à l'heure que 50 ans nelin n'avait
pas rougir de ce qui se faisait sur
Paris on va juste regarder tout de même
un chiffre le chiffre du jour 2,5
millions de personnes ont participé à
Paris à l'édition 2011 de la Nuit
Blanche combien de personnes vous
attendez à C quanttin en Yveline cette
année alors combien de person 2 million
et demi de personnes toutit en plus la
météo est un facteur déterminant dans
ces soirées puisque l'année dernière il
faut se rappeler qu'on avait eu un
superbe temps qui nous avait permis
d'accueillir à 50h en yeline plus de
2000 personnes lors de la Nuit Blanche
la météo du weekend qui arrive s'annonce
un tout petit peu plus mouvementé donc
on verra bien ce qu'on va pouvoir
proposer mais la nuit blanche à 51 en
iveline aura lieu goutte que goutte
goutte que goutte qu'il pleuve ou qu'il
ne pleuvent pas vous aurez une solution
de de repli on le verra d'ailleurs alors
quels sont les sites qui sont concernés
cette année au tout début il y a 3 ans
la première participation vous étiez
plutôt du côté de la médiathèque du
canal sur montinil Bretonneux c'est plus
le cas cette année tout à fait on a
proposé donc pendant 2 ans une nuit
blanche à la médiathèque du canal cette
année ce sont plutôt deux pôles très
opposés de la ville nouvelle que nous
allons occuper enfin de l'agglomération
51 en evveline la ferme de Bel etbas
avec une nuit de la de la poésie
proposée en partenariat avec la maison
de la poésie dans le cadre de Poé
Yveline et une nuit blanche sur le
quartier des 7 mars à Saint-Quentin en
Yveline donc quartier un petit peu
historique culturellement puisque c'est
lui qui a vu apparaître la première
structure culturelle intercommunale la
pasque donc on va investir le cartier on
va pouvoir se retrouver sur le parc de
l'homme couché avec la proposition
chorégraphique donc qui invite 120
habitants de Saint-Quentin à participer
à la création d'un spectacle tout ça
mené par l'équipe de Jean-Claude galota
donc qui dirige le Centre chorégraphique
national de grenob de Grenoble euh on va
avoir aussi des propositions à la
médiathèque des 7mars avec plusieurs
animations l'école de musique l'école de
danse l'association créad des lectures
de comptes donc de nombreuses
propositions des performances de
plasticiens puisque la commanderie des
Templiers de la ville Dieu et ses
propositions art plastique se
déplaceront donc au centre du quartier
des 7 mars sous le passage au B pour des
performances dessinées puisque cette
année nous accueillons une résidence de
SEP dessinateurs vous avez associés
justement tous les tous les artistes en
résidence un petit peu duur son les
artistes en résidence les structures
culturell arstes du street art qui sont
en résidence ça c'était ceux de l'année
dernière que nous avions associé pour le
street art qui avait d'ailleurs fait une
performance euh devant la médiiathèque
donc chaque année vous reprenez les
artistes qui sont là et vous travaillez
avec eux c'est un travail qui est asse
qui est assez long en fait hein TR la
ché le travail sur la chorégraphie avec
Jean-Claude Galotta donc c'est un projet
qui est né il y a un peu plus d'un an
dans l'esprit de l'équipe du prisme he
puisque c'est le prisme qui porte ce
projet dans le cadre de la Nuit Blanche
les rencontres avec les habitants ont
commencé au mois de mars avril et les
répétitions au mois de juillet pour se
continuer tout le mois de septembre et
enc le weekend dernier et sûrement
demain soir en extérieur j'espère et ces
répétitions nous les avons suivies
justement représentation de la pièce
chorégraphique l'élan de Jean-Claude
Galotta ce sera lors de ces nuit
blanches du côté d'élan cours comment se
déroule les répétitions avec ses
amateurs Joann sououdri Patrick Jacques
de
dix Marie lur éit l courtoise elle avait
participé l'année dernière au projet de
danse mené par Olivier Dubois au prisme
comblé par cette expérience artistique
marielore s'est inscrite au nouvel
atelier du chorégraphe Jean-Claude
galottin je trouve que c'est une
occasion extraordinaire de danser avec
des gens qu'on connaît pas forcément de
de T niveau qu'on soit simple danseur ou
bien un peu plus expérimenté et ce lien
qui se crée entre nous et le plaisir de
danser est une expérience à partager une
expérience à partager entre plusieurs
générations c'est le défi de Jean-Claude
Galotta réunir et faire danser des
amateurs de tous âge pour la nuit
blanche de SaintQuentin en
evveline a des enfants en fait 50
enfants
après il donne la place à 50 adultes qui
refont un peu des gestes qu'on a un peu
vu avec eux et puis ensuite tous les
gens se déplacent et vont sur
l'esplanade et là il voit la troè
génération en fait des des personnes
âgées qui qui refont d'autres gestes et
quand ces personnes âgées ont terminé en
fait toutes les générations se
retrouvent sur l'esplanade et font une
danse où il y a 150 danseurs en fait je
trouvais ça mag magnifique cette idée
que tout le monde peut être danseur et
que tout le monde peut danser de de la
maternelle jusqu'à la tombe le groupe
des seniors répète depuis le mois de
juin avec Yannick assistant de
Jean-Claude galota c'est une expérience
assez touchante je trouve de voir le
mouvement traverser les corps en fait
qui ont pas l'habitude de bouger et puis
voilà voir toutes les étapes du travail
aussi bien le début les corps qui sont
complètement
fermés au mouvement et qui au bout de 3
semaines de travail s'ouvre complètement
25 personnes de 50 à 82 ans composent le
groupe numéro 3 un groupe très assidu et
motivé aujourd'hui justement on
travaille sur la précision et on se rend
compte qu'on a interprété chacun des
gestes à notre façon avec notre style
alors il y a des fois on nous dit que
c'est bien il y a des fois au contraire
c'est pas bien du tout il faut être très
strict un cours de danse qui réserve
bien des surprises une de nous et qui
n'était de loin pas la plus jeune qui a
fait le grand écart devant nos yeux
ébailis prochaine étape la rencontre
avec les autres groupes pour la suite
des répétitions avant le spectacle final
interprété au pristhme à encour lors de
la Nuit Blanche de saqutin ivine le
samedi 6
octobre tout est prêt les répétitions se
poursuivent mais s'il pleut que va-t-il
se passer vous avez une solution de
repli s'il pleut on a le plan B donc le
plan B c'est effectivement de proposer
les représentations de l'élan à
l'intérieur du prisme en salle ce qui
n'est pas le projet initial mais en tous
les cas qui permettra qu'il se joue et
au lieu de le proposer deux fois on le
proposera trois fois dans la soirée là
on a vu donc les amateurs sont associés
à ce projet la nuit blanche c'est ça
véritablement c'est l'idée de d'associer
la population de la faire découvrir
différemment les les lieux culturels
historiques de la ville l'agglomération
en tous les cas c'est comme ça qu'on l'a
qu'on la conçoit à Saint-Quentin en
yeline c'est comme ça que les
partenaires s'y associent aussi c'est
aussi pour nous très important que la
population s'empare de ces projet je
veux dire on fait ça pour eux vers eux
mais aussi avec eux et ça c'est très
très important dans notre démarche la
nuit blanche c'est pas un rendez-vous
élitiste faut pas être initié faut pas
être parisien on peut le faire aussi à 5
en Yveline donc on a bien compris c'est
pas un moment initié on peut venir en
famille aussi même si c'est le soir et
que c'est la nu on peut venir en famille
on veille à avoir vraiment des
propositions pour tous les âges et pour
tous les goûts on peut avoir aussi bien
de la poésie si on participe à la nuit
blanche de la poésie que du cinéma
puisque que le prisme va ouvrir ses
portes les portes de la petite salle au
ciné en attendant donc la fin des
travaux de façon à ce que le cineset
puisse aussi proposer un programme avec
trois réalisateurs Julie Dumont Ricardo
Muno et Dominique àu donc c'est pour
nous une très grande ouverture c'est de
la musique c'est de la danse c'est du
compte c'est une rencontre aussi avec
des auteurs puisque la librairie
s'associe à la nuit blanche cette année
et proposera trois rencontres re une
rencontre avec Séverine Vidal qui est
auteur jeunesse une avec mighty Goldman
qui est un auteur du territoire qui
écrit des roman adulte et voilà et Mario
Urbanet qu'on ne présente plus illustre
compteur cquantinois qu'on retrouvera à
la médiathèque et à la librairie c'est
presque trop court juste une soirée pour
la Nuit Blanche c'est presque un
festival le programme que vous nous
donnez c'est peut-être un peu trop court
en tous les cas nous on souhaite
vraiment que les gens puissent prendre
du plaisir à picorer à passer d'une
animation à l'autre en toute liberté en
toute fluidité de découvrir aussi ce
quartier sous un autre angle puisque le
musée de la ville sera présent et
proposera trois éclairages sur
l'architecture du quartier en présentant
l'œuvre de l'homme couché la main
céleste en présentant le carillon qui se
trouve au-dessus du cinéma et tout le
monde oublie c'est une œuvre d'art publi
et en présentant aussi le principe
architectural des immeubles des vagues
qui se trouvent au cœur du quartier donc
ces trois V visites auront lieu par le
musée de la ville de façon aussi à ce
que ce quartier a une histoire
Saint-Quentin en iveline à 40 ans et
tout ça en fait partie donc le cœur le
gros du programme ce sera du côté
d'élancour pour cette nuit blanche il y
aura aussi cette Nuit de la poésie
puisque la Maison de la Poésie y
participe et quel sera votre programme
pour la Nuit Blanche avez-vous peut-être
déjà entendu parler aussi de la nuit
blanche on va le voir avec ce micro
trottoir ben je pe-être me renseigner si
le Musée de la Mode est ouvert et y
aller moi je vais sûement à Paris pour
la Nuit Blanche ah ben je ne sais pas
j'en ai pas ah alors euh
ouais c'est pas tellement ma tasse de
thé ça d'accord je suis plus euh
promenade en forêt ah bah aucun
programme pour moi bah écoutez je suis
jamais allée à la nuit blanche avant
donc faudrait que je regarde un peu ce
qu'il y a sur internet donc voilà je
sais pas en fait j'ai pas du tout
réfléchi mais oui les monuments offire
un peu tout le tour des
monuments de Paris oui peut-être aller à
Paris euh il a peut-être des animations
dans le métro c'est ça l'ann dernière
c'était station fantô je
crois c'est pas fait exprès mais on
parle beaucoup de Paris dans le micro
trottoir bah oui mais restez à 5 en
yeline on a des propositions pour vous
de nom pas assz connu encore peut-être
la manifestation des nuits blanches
alors peut-être que la manifestation des
nuit blanches qui est quand même très
parisienne et qui commence depuis 2 3
ans à s'étendre sur la région Île de
France mais aussi dans des grandes
villes de
France commence à à avoir son public euh
c'est aussi peut-être lié à une démarche
très axée sur la découverte de monuments
et très accè à l'art contemporain donc
on en propose aussi mais pas seulement
et ben pour ça j'invite le public à être
curieux et à se rendre au quartier des
semars ou à la ferme de belébas pour
voir que la nuit blanche c'est des
propositions pour tous ouvertes à tous
et ce sera votre programme vous serez du
côté des lancour je pense que je serai
du côté des lancour et vous allez pas
aller à Paris pour les nuits blanchesand
même vous allez rester sur saquentins en
nieline merci Sandy Descoins donc
responsable de l'événementiel pour la
communauté d'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin le programme de la nuit
blanche sur 5quent ans nivelin et puis
sur Paris si vous ne voulez décidément
pas rester à Saint-Quentin en Yveline
sont à retrouver sur les sites Internet
qui se sont affichés la suite du 78
c'est avec la chronique écho d'Alice
Gastine il sera question d'intelligence
économique auparavant et alors que la
semaine du handicap va s'ouvrir le 8
octobre à Montini nous allons visiter un
atelier d'art plastique pour des
personnes en situation de handicap cela
se déroule dans les locaux de l'APF de
l'Association des Paralysés de France à
voisin le breteneux vous allez donc
faire connaissance avec gislen elle
découvre la
linogravure gislen le nouvel découvre la
linogravure sur une plaque elle
reproduit un tableau qu'elle a choisi
les Ninfa de Mony le geste des mains est
lent gisl souffre d'un handicap moteur
depuis l'enfance j'essaie de faire au
mieux faire au mieux et faire bien une
fois par semaine des ateliers d'art
plastique sont ainsi proposé par
l'Association des Paralysés de France
installé à voisin le Bretonneux on
essaie de s'adapter avec les moyens du
bord et puis on trouve des petites
astuces selon ce qu'on fait vous vous
trouvez quelle astuce par exemple pour
graver parce que la gravure c'est quand
même un exercice en fait j'ai trouvé
d'autres m pour m'aider à te dire la
plaque et après moi je fais le reste ici
dans cet atelier de peinture et de
gravure h élèves sont inscrits ils sont
handicapés moteurs pour la plupart le
temps de l'atelier on oublie un peu tout
pour déjà avir les copines et puis
progresser dans la peinture au début je
savais pas du tout peindre maintenant
j'arrive mieux à faire des dessins je me
débrouille de faire des choses comme ça
c'est c'est une évasion c'est oublier
les petits soucis enne comme tout le
monde c'est pas toujours simple mais
justement on essaie d'évoluer hein pour
progresser malgré ces difficultés voilà
se dire qu'on peut quand même évoluer
pour VO c'est vraiment dans l'idée d'une
prise de confiance en soi et donc voilà
évoluer dans ce qu'on peut faire en art
plastique ces ateliers sont également
ouverts aux personnes valides une
exposition commune de peinture et de
sculpture aura lieu à la fin de l'année
il faudrait mettre